hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry today
we're gonna check out a video now I'm
gonna be damned today I'm Dan cyber
we're not doing your gay boys that Bruce
are [ __ ] what's his name hey everybody
I'm Dan Seibert this is nerd boys that's
a gay voice yeah you did we're checking
out this video it's highly requested
called dammit Shia I'm assuming it's one
of those spliced videos of Shia LaBeouf
speech hey didn't I tell you yesterday I
was calling the cops yesterday you said
tomorrow so just do it how are you even
getting up here that's an impossible
client are you jumping down from the
roof or something joy I swear to God if
you're jumping down from up there
god damn it Shia that was definetly
amusing green-screen was good enough oh
yeah yeah I mean the edges are rough but
the motion is all good yeah it looked
good and you know worthy review right
here ya know as fun as that was amusing
no that is impressive I've seen a lot
I've seen a lot of like especially
online like vines and [ __ ] people doing
these parodies of it but that was a
decent that was not bad it's not bad
this is a worthy video for you guys to
be here with us today 30 seconds of
Awesomeness that you just experienced
with us you worked so hard on this
channel anyway guys thanks for tuning
into the reject channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects if you
happen to like this hard piece of art
that we just presented to you and you
could check out Jerry's latest reasons
yeah and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where if we get
enough followers or we can get product
placement for things such as if you come
here for a second please
what just come here for one second
mail-order threesome hooker this is no
Jerry's the male oh yeah I had to
include him if you want if you want a
threesome and you don't want it awkward
with someone you know and you want it to
be a guy you get someone like Jerry
that's the reason a Jerry you know so
follow us kidnaps you puts you in a box
and ships you to someone's house to be
had sex with I want sponsorship for male
prostitute I'm going to take my hand off
of Jerry's lay thank you thank you for
doing that for me
male process